good morning everybody great to see a
full room
to listen to me talk about oat I'm going
to talk about the insecurity of all art
in front that's so um title doesn't
really hide anything it's pretty blunt
um that's also going to be the tldr
version award in front lens is insecure
I'm going to explain why exactly I'm
going to show you why exactly and I'll
hint at some solutions that we can
actually apply to make a lot more secure
and how you should be doing a lot in any
kind of sensitive application when
you're dealing with web-based front ends
all right that's essentially the story
for today I'm going to start with oh out
and by going back at when the spec was
created the spec was introduced or 2.0
and back then that was about 11 12-ish
years ago so that's a long time ago
especially if you look at application
development web development back then we
were building a server-side web
applications and that's basically the
main use case for oad back then was like
yeah we have a server-side application
that would like to access another server
in the name of the user and you had a
whole flow to go through these steps I'm
kind of guessing if you're here that you
are familiar with Olaf I'm not going to
walk you through any of the oauth flows
today so that might be a big relief for
some of you like oh not again all the
different steps with the authorization
code we're not going to really talk
about that but the original spec also
had some other use cases there were four
flows back then of which only one really
survived maybe one and a half something
like that but we have some support for
mobile applications front-end
applications but they're not really
first class citizens right there are
some like yeah yeah you can do something
for web apps nobody cares because
nobody's doing JavaScript based
applications or not really a bit a lot
back then but of course things change
over time and it turns out that mobile
apps became a big thing and a lot of
work was done on mobile a lot of
problems arise like oh crap we probably
have to deal with that and this and that
and eventually you got a spec dedicated
to Native apps which in for a main part
is mobile apps and they added a couple
of security guidelines and additional
features and so on and then things
started evolving and all of a sudden
people were doing all these web contents
angular apps react apps and they run as
a standalone app in Nebraska and of
course Standalone apps in the browsers
they can do some useful things and one
of these things should be a wide
receiver that's not very useful in the
front-end app but oh out because then
you can get access tokens to access apis
so front-end web apps become first-class
citizens as well and we see that today
because there are specs like there's an
oauth for browser-based apps it's a
draft but it's considered to be a fairly
mature draft with some security
guidelines and so on to deal with
front-end applications that's
essentially Where We Are
and that's what I'm going to talk about
here today I'm going to talk about web
front lens how they work and what the
challenges are when dealing with web
front ends if you want to see it by the
way people in the back there's some free
seats up front Prime seats uh
on the floor it's the best best place in
the house especially because the people
in the back have trouble seeing the
bottom of the slide so uh all right so
when we talk about front ends we talk
about JavaScript that's essentially how
things are built in the browser you may
be using some other language that
eventually transpiles into JavaScript
anyway and there's a couple of
Alternatives but the bulk here is
Javascript code and we talk about
JavaScript there's this famous picture
of JavaScript the definitive guide and
then JavaScript the good parts and in
front then you have something similar
when we talk about JavaScript you have
to almost say in the same red malicious
JavaScript that's the way things are and
we have to account for evil JavaScript
ending up in an application can happen
in various ways you can install a
malicious dependency from npm it's
basically like a bingo at this time 50
chance of getting the right one or the
wrong one
if you include remote code files or like
yeah let's load some file from a
third-party service provider they might
get attacked and you get malicious code
in your application or we have
cross-site scripting where the attacker
provides data to the application there's
a mistake there and that data becomes
executable code
three very common attack factors that we
have to talk about
these attack factors are really common
here's a graph from hacker one bug
Bounty platform major boundary platform
they had a top 10 of vulnerabilities a
couple years ago and number one the
yellow par 23 is acting cross-at
scripting I'm not exactly sure because
they call it xxs instead of xss which is
like abbreviation problems but in
essence Crosshair scripting is a main
threat nobody's arguing with that
there's no there's a general consensus
that says like yeah Crosshair scripting
remains a big threat it has been for 20
something years and it's still a threat
today it's gotten better in front-end
apps better in angular particular but
also in react and View and all of these
things but it's still there and it's
still a problem
and we all know that and even the the
oauth spec knows about this because if
you look at this browser-based app spec
you'll find plenty of mentions about
crosstipting and statements like yeah
cross-site scripting is a big risk and
we have to be careful and so on as well
so that's essentially where we are
nobody's arguing with that
all right good
what does that mean
well that's the takeaway here malicious
JavaScript remains a big threat even
though I wish it wasn't um with all the
measures we have it's still there it's
still something we have to account for
and everybody generally agrees on that
it's part of the OS top 10 as well
number three uh injection part of that
is cross-site scripting so the question
is what does that mean for your oauth
tokens
that's the question I'm going to try to
answer in this talk if you want a sneak
preview it's not good
I may have even let the f word slip out
yesterday when I answered somebody's
question in Dominic's talk uh so yeah
it's it's not going to be very good and
that's the rest of this stock so first a
quick word about me I'm Philip Drake I'm
from Belgium and I did a PhD in web
security so I'm kind of a security
expert and I've been doing security for
a very long time
what I do um day-to-day is I run a
company called pragmatic web security so
I help developers understand Security in
workshops I did a conference Workshop
here two days on Monday and Tuesday
where we talked about cross-et scripting
among other things I do online courses
and I do highly specialized Consulting
as well I'm a at zero Ambassador and a
Google developer expert so I don't work
for these companies it's just they have
like a right they recognize if you do a
lot for the community like docs and
articles and stuff like that and that's
why they like to send me free swag every
now and then which I appreciate very
much and then I mention them in my talks
so that makes them very happy but at
xeros here if you want to learn more
about what they do they have a boot so I
go talk to Sam and his colleagues if you
want
and then finally I also run a course in
Belgium it's a non-profit course called
SEC updev which is about secure
application development we bring in
experts in their field bring them to
live in Belgium where they teach about
application security for a full week so
that's absolutely awesome first of all
it's in Belgium so that's pretty cool we
have awesome an awesome environment
great lunches and a lot of interesting
talks and my friends Steiner here up
front he is going to come to Second Dev
this year so he's the official delegate
now for Norway so if you want to come to
secular death he's going to handle he's
going to book a plane and no I'm just
kidding but
maybe we can Charter a plane from Norway
that would be awesome man but seriously
I'll look it up it's pretty awesome but
that's enough about me let's talk about
a lot let's talk about browser-based
apps if you read this statement in the
spec I chose this quote for a reason on
the previous slide it's because it talks
about a danger with Crosshair scripting
token exfiltration
sounds super fancy in essence it comes
down to the attacker injects malicious
code in the application and they're able
to steal tokens
what tokens access tokens and refresh
tokens that's the threat that we want to
talk about so how would an attack like
that work let me show you what that
means in practice
here we have our victim application
that's my training app called restograde
it's a restaurant review app very simple
very straightforward it handles reviews
from people all over the world awesome
and the app is just running as it is it
runs some oauth stuff interacts with the
authorization server that's where you
use the authorization code flow with
Pixie and all of the steps which I'm not
going to talk about here today
good
the app typically stores tokens
somewhere local storage session storage
index DB whatever the tokens are going
to be somewhere and they have to be
somewhere because the app needs them to
attach them on outgoing requests to the
API so the tokens are somewhere in the
app that is a common scenario
the question is what happens when the
attacker shows up that's a piece of
malicious code so at some point
something happens in the app malicious
code ends up in there and the attacker
now executes code inside the application
that's how cross-site scripting works or
malicious dependencies or Savannah so on
that code executes in the application so
what is the attacker gonna do
the attacker reads that storage very
easy the attacker can just read the
storage get all the data out of storage
and send it off to a server controlled
by the attacker just a simple request a
get request a post request whatever
Anything Goes and the data from that
storage now goes to the server detector
they see the data coming in like oh
those are tokens awesome and they can
use the access token to contact an API
in the name of the user
that is token exfiltration very very
common attack scenario very
well-known scenario this is not
something new this is not like oh my God
we never thought of that of course not
everybody knows about this the spec
knows about this
and there's a whole bunch of
countermeasures to try and prevent these
things from causing trouble
one of the guidelines is
you should keep your access tokens
short-lived because if the access token
that's used in step 3 is only valid for
5 or 10 minutes then the damage the
window of abuse is limited to 5 to 10
minutes
that's good especially because those
tokens are typically jots Json web
tokens that are not revocable or there's
no infrastructure to revoke them during
their lifetime
all right the second guideline you'll
find in the spec is like you have to use
refresh token rotation
because the refresh tokens in front-end
web apps are better refresh tokens
if you cut if you remember anything from
Dominic stock from yesterday and
Steiners it's that bear tokens are not
very secure meaning that if the attacker
gets hold of a refresh token they can
now use it with the authorization server
to get fresh tokens and that's why the
specs is like yeah that's not good
you have to use refresh token rotation
to counter that here's how refresh token
rotation works
there's a timeline I'm gonna walk over
here so I can see this part of the
audience as well there's a timeline from
left to right and the app is going to
request tokens from the authorization
server using the authorization code flow
and so on and they get access token 1
and refresh token 1. and access token 1
is valid for 10 minutes
and then after I should probably go back
because there's a camera I forgot about
that it always catches me access token 1
expires after 10 minutes and the app is
going to be like after nine minutes you
know what I'm gonna get a new one and
it's going to use refresh token 1 to get
access token 2 and it also gets refresh
token too for the next time you need one
and after nine minutes access token 2
expires so the app uses rt2 to get token
set 3 and then token 3 is about to
expire access token 3 it uses refresh
token 3 to get token set 4 and so on and
so on until some kind of absolute
lifetime is his reached and then the
authorization services like no done
refresh token rotation
by itself this doesn't really add much
except a bit of complexity but there's a
second part to this story and the second
part is that if the authorization server
sees a refresh token twice
it assumes that something fishy is going
on because the legitimate app is not
going to decide halfway through like you
know what I liked refresh token 2 from
like 10 minutes ago I'm gonna use that
one instead of the new one the
legitimate app is not gonna do that well
maybe if you write some crappy
JavaScript code it might do that but
that's not supposed to happen so what is
the idea here the idea is that you have
did yet if the attacker comes in and
steals refresh token 2 at some time
and they use it they will get access
token 3 and refresh token 3. that's not
good they now have access to an API in
the name of the user along with the
refresh token but the app is unaware
that this happened so after a while the
app is like hey I'm going to use refresh
token 2 as well and the authorization
service like you're gonna do what now no
I've already seen that one that's not
good
I'm going to assume somebody else used
that in your place that's not good so
it's going to revoke not if your new
tokens is going to revoke existing
tokens so rt3 becomes invalid so in the
future the attacker no longer has access
to that token chain all of the tokens
are invalidated basically
that's good right
that's a good security measure because
now even if a token is stolen
we can prevent it from being abused in
the long term awesome
when I first heard about this it seems
like oh yeah that that kind of makes
sense
and you start thinking about this and if
you think about this for a while it's
like
wait what
it highly depends on the fact that this
token rt2 is observed twice
but what if it's only seen once
then nothing happens
and if nothing happens and the attacker
has that token they can use it until the
absolute lifetime is reached let's say
you log in now lifetime is eight hours I
steal it in 30 minutes and that means I
would have access for 7 hours and 30
minutes well it depends on what the
application is whether how bad that's
going to be but that's not supposed to
happen so how would an attacker do that
well very simple
here's the scenario the attacker does
the same thing steals the token sends
them off to their server and keeps track
of them and then they just wait
they wait and maybe they repeat step one
and two if there's new tokens refresh
token two and three and four and they
wait until the application goes offline
damn it stupid
camera we wait until the application
goes offline
because guess what if it goes offline it
means you close the tab close to your
browser disconnect it from the network
are on a plane whatever and the attack
is like ah you're not going to use your
latest refresh token awesome I am thank
you
and the attacker resumes that refresh
token chain and has access for the
remaining lifetime of that chain that is
a
fairly trivial way to bypass refresh
token rotation
and that's essentially a takeaway here
is that token exfiltration attacks
like focusing on the attacker
exfiltrating the token and things like
that they severely underrepresent the
capabilities of malicious JavaScript
because an attacker can do so much more
and that's essentially a very important
message the attacker can do anything a
legitimate front-end application can do
and they can write sophisticated
JavaScript code not the 12 year old
script KD version of Steel tokens and
abuse them
they can be a bit smarter about that
that's essentially what I'm trying to
see here I'm going to try to show you
that in a demo I'm not a big fan of
doing live Demos in golf rocks for
obvious reasons so I'm going to screw it
up uh probably but uh let's take the
tourney together then shall we
I'm gonna try to show this I've been
talking about this for a while and it's
very hard to really grasp what this
means in practice I'm going to try to
demonstrate to see um what this means
all right what do we have setup wise we
have
an application here
okay disclaimer I am not a good designer
so please give me some got me some slack
on the application so we have
app.restigrade like I said it looks like
crap
we have app.resquery.com and this is a
simple app it has a search feature we'll
come back to that later but in essence
it's an application where we can log in
as a user using a lot so I'm using r0
here to log into restograde very simple
my password is like test something
something and here we go
so we log into the application it now
knows who I am that's open ID connect
identity token and it has a bunch of
tokens and you will see here at the
bottom in a few seconds that it's using
a refresh token to obtain the next
refresh token so it's basically running
a refresh token flow and using refresh
token rotation so you'll see this token
change over time that's essentially
what's going on very simple very
straightforward
all right onto the attack
as the attacker I have written
my server side code is not prettier
either but sure whatever I've written a
malicious server the malicious server is
basically that server running it's going
to accept tokens and abuse tokens when
it wants to and it's very simple it
basically has a data endpoint to accept
incoming data including the refresh
token and then it will abuse that later
on I'm also going to launch an attack
file from here
we have attack.gs here's the full
payload to steal tokens from the
application it's not even minimized so
we can actually read it but basically we
send a fetch request a post request and
we include the data from session storage
in that request and that's how we steal
that all right
how do we exploit that well let me copy
paste that from my street sheet here's
that's the search feature this is a
croset scripting vulnerability so what
happens here is we load the app with the
search term I send you a link to the
restaurant review app with search for
like Indian food in Oslo and you'll end
up on the search page and you can see
that we populate your search results for
test that value test is the value from
the URL inserted into the application
this is called reflected xss very
typical attack scenario seriously if you
find search features on websites you can
probably have used them to cross that
scripting very very common vulnerability
as well
so how do we exploit that well here's
the actual this doesn't do anything I
mean it shows test that's not dangerous
but here's the attack we
search for test
and we also add an SVG image that we
don't really display but when the SVG
loads we want to insert the script tag
into the page and load that attack.js
file that's essentially a common way to
attack an application so let's do that
let me clear this one let's insert this
into the page
all right now you can see here our
malicious server is running here it's
basically receiving that refresh token
um and it also has a heartbeat so it
detects that the application is alive
because every couple of seconds we're
like here's the token here's the token
and this the application is still alive
message is basically uh the the check on
the server side like every second or
something it checks like you see
application still there yes or no so
what this now means is if we
the application is still using refresh
Docker rotation no reuse everything
works as expected until we leave the
application we're gonna do something
else like look at my website for example
and
here you'll see in a second there's a
timer out of like 10 seconds something
like that that like oh the application
didn't respond anymore interesting and
you can see here bam there we go getting
ready to view tokens and it's now
refreshing tokens kind of aggressively
but uh just to show you that it has
taken over that refresh token change
from the application so the attacker now
has access in your name and you can do
whatever they want for the foreseeable
future
all right
let me kill this before adzir gets angry
at me
all right that was sidestepping refresh
token rotation
very simple very straightforward
seriously a real attacker can probably
make this a bit cleaner and
sophisticated more sophisticated but it
kind of gets the point across I think
yes sir
in this scenario of course the attacker
and the locked and user with the same
person so to make it a realistic thing
an attacker would get a locked user too
okay
yes so in in this scenario I'm of course
both a user and the attacker because
otherwise the demo would get really
complicated but um in in reality you
would be the user absolutely and I would
just send you a link like we have a
slack Channel I just send in like the
general slack channel for the conference
like hey man check out these awesome
reviews and you're like click and then
behind the scenes my code loads your
tokens get sent to me and I'm like I'm
now whoever you are and I can send
requests to the API of restaurant I can
start adding reviews and says like oh my
God this restaurant is really bad and
promote the restaurant of one of my
friends and so on and so on like I know
not really harmful but imagine that the
restaurant review app is a healthcare
app or a financial app then gets
real uh real fast but yeah that's
essentially what I'm trying to show
thank you for asking for clarification
oh yeah absolutely I just used reflected
Crosshair scripting because it's very
visible and is stored exercise attack
the data would end up in the database
like one of the reviews with some SVG
stuff that gets rendered and the attack
the the attack factor is the same I
could also compromise a third-party
scripter including probably one of your
marketing guys added Google tag manager
with some crap and if I compromise one
of those scripts it gets included and I
can do the same any piece of JavaScript
that I control that executes in the
victim application gives me that control
that power that's essentially what it is
and the main takeaway here is that
refresh token rotation is not a security
measure it gets sold as one in the spec
but it's really not
because if you look at the real power of
JavaScript it can't stop these attacks a
somewhat sophisticated attack and we'll
be able to bypass the security measure
anyway and it doesn't really buy you
anything except for a false sense of
security
create more problems for the legitimate
application than for the attacker yes
this guy implements identity servers
right
because you get stories like yeah but
what just to give you an example what if
the response to getting a new refresh
token gets lost like crappy Network poof
and the application never received it so
next time it's going to use the old
token but the authorization service like
no no so we have Solutions like here but
what if we allow like a tiny window of
reuse because might happen and like
seriously there's a lot of corner cases
that pop up
where this gets a bit messy to deal with
um but we can talk about that later
so full power of JavaScript
gives the attackers a lot of
capabilities
and that also means that is token
exfiltration it seems super important
but honestly it really really isn't but
if you look at the spec
the browser-based app spec if you look
for token exfiltration
they hammer on it nine times in the spec
like oh my God built connect filtration
we have the focus on token exfiltration
because of reasons like the exfol
trading tokens and being able to abuse
those refresh tokens people have the
idea but what if we can stop that token
from leaving in the first place
because if you can't get the token then
you can't abuse it we gotcha and there's
a lot of work being done I'm trying to
prevent this and it doesn't work
well it might work there's actually
effective patterns to hide the refresh
token that's good you can keep it in a
web worker the adziro SDK is doing that
by default which is good it's a good
pattern but it doesn't help it doesn't
secure your application because guess
what as an attacker I don't need the
application's tokens
as an attacker I can do other things I'm
going to inject my code and then the
application can do whatever it wants
with their tokens I'm going to get fresh
tokens for myself new tokens and with
those new tokens I can do whatever I
want let me walk you through the
scenario and I have a demo coming up as
well so same premise the application
running on the user's browser has some
malicious code that is being executed a
malicious code
doesn't care about existing tokens it's
like whatever
the app has tokens it has been it has an
authenticated user the user has logged
in with an authorization server there is
an active session so you know what this
code is going to do it's going to be
like okay
I'm assuming there's an active session
I'm going to run a silent authentication
flow in an iframe a very well supported
a lot feature silent flow meaning it's
going to set up a listener for messages
coming from iframes it's going to load a
hidden iframe in the page and in that
iframe it's going to run an
authorization flow asking the
authorization server for an
authorization code which will get tokens
and it's going to set prompt To None
meaning like don't prompt the user don't
request user interaction just give me a
code if a user exists and that request
goes out and the browser is like hey hey
you're asking the authorization server
for something I have a cookie there a
session that's how single sign-on works
that's how silent renew works that's how
an application can bootstrap state with
an authenticated user without requiring
a login if there's an active session
and when the attacker does that the
browser attaches the cookie the
authorization service like I know who
you are you flip from five minutes ago
awesome here you go
and the authorization code comes back my
Handler from Step One receives that
authorization code I ship it off to the
server controlled by me and I exchange
that code for tokens
and now I have a completely independent
set of tokens
unrelated to the applications tokens the
application has access token 1 and
refresh token one
I now have access token a and refresh
token a completely unrelated
and that's a bit of a problem
this new set of tokens is fully
independent it will never run into
problems like refresh token rotation and
so on and that is as bad as it gets for
front-end applications
let me try and show you how that works
all right
let me
run this malicious server
there we go the app is the same same app
same vulnerability so let me show you
what we're gonna do we are not gonna do
this one
but we're gonna run this the attack file
is a bit more complicated because now we
have to run an oauth flow so we're going
to basically let me walk you through it
we're going to set up that listener at
the end here so we're gonna listen for
incoming messages containing at the
authorization code that's a frame to the
parent message we're going to register
an iframe here
we're going to hide it of course in the
live stream we're going to use the URL
to bootstrap a flow and that's the flow
that takes us to the authorization
server includes the client ID and so on
and so on which I of course got by
exploring the restaurant application in
the first place and when we get the
authorization code we send it to the
server of the attacker and off we go
all right the server of the attacker
that's this one
will obtain the authorization code here
no let's use it obtain it here so we
just accept a request right here then we
use it which means we're going to
exchange it with the authorization
server for tokens we'll get an access
token and a refresh token because as far
as the authorization server is concerned
we're a legitimate front-end app it
doesn't know any better
and we can exchange use those tokens
later on and that's essentially what
will happen all right
the attack the payload is the same
we have the same app same way of loading
that attack file as well so let me
show you how that works
I'm gonna
show the network tab here
so you can actually see that hidden flow
in the iframe happening in practice so
the app is loading it's running let me
click login so it gets fresh tokens all
is good and if in a couple of seconds
you'll see a new authorization request
pass by
always exciting
where is it
okay it's not coming apparently well
seems like
I screwed up the demo
let me try again
yeah my payload was gone so that's why
so the payload is loaded now and there's
an interval there's there it is that's
the height and iframe flow to run an art
rice flow the response will send an
authorization code to the application
which ships it off to the server of the
attacker that's a data request right
here and here you can see that the
attacker has received the authorization
code on top let me scroll here so we can
see that receive the authorization code
we're exchanging the code for tokens
that was the code here's an access token
which I abbreviated because it's a very
long jot and here's the refresh token
and now we can just keep renewing that
and the conclusion here is that in your
application as a front-end developer you
can be the best developer in the world
on high tokens somewhere nobody can ever
get to them
for malicious JavaScript and it doesn't
matter because malicious JavaScript can
just ask for new tokens and everybody's
like yeah sure here you go
and that's essentially What's Happening
Here
all right
and to link it back to
Steiners and Dominic talk from yesterday
they talked about proof of possession in
case you weren't there proof of
possession meaning that these tokens are
linked to a secret that the client holds
guess what in this it would happen in
step five when you exchange the code for
tokens and the attacker can easily
include their own d-pop Secrets uh well
use their deep up secret with a public
key to link the tokens to uh or the yeah
the new tokens to their secret so this
is not going to stop any of it that's
why we talked about this yesterday
briefly we mentioned like this is not
going to solve your X's consequences
this is why because an attacker can just
provide a depop secret and proof as well
this is basically
not good
that's the summary here this is not good
as in the conclusion is you cannot
secure browser only a lot flows because
this attack Factor
there's no way to plug it because it all
relies on the fact that if we send the
authorization code back to the clients
we send it to a specific origin you have
to approve that redirect URI and we
assume that that's a trusted location
it's not going to end up on a malicious
application
and that's true but if the attacker
controls that legitimate origin of the
application the attacker has full access
to these things and
the security comes crumbling down like a
heart of cards basically like a bunch of
dominoes it stops working
and this
conclusion is really really inconvenient
seriously because for a couple of
reasons because first of all
a lot of people want to build
front-end-only apps that access apis and
this is like oh crap that's not good
second of all we have this whole spec
trying to fix this and a message is like
ah you can't so that's not good
and then we we've as a community have
been telling people for a long time like
yeah this is how you do front-end or out
apps and I was like ah no we're just
kidding you can't and
and that's really really inconvenient
and as a consequence to this I've been
talking about this for a while by the
way for about one and a half two years
and the off the the reaction I often get
is like yeah but what if
and people come up with all kinds of
solutions and one of the solutions you
actually find in the spec the edit this
in December and I'm risking coming off
as like old man yelling at Cloud here
but
I really have to do this part somebody
said like yeah but we can use a service
worker and service workers are give you
the ability to intercept HTTP requests
coming from a client and modify them in
the browser and what they said is like
we can register a service worker that
will handle all the oauth stuff and if
the application tries to run an O
outflow directly with the authorization
server we can stop it we can block it
it's like
sure
if you can do that that sounds like a
good idea because you're like adding a
component that handles all out but
remember you're still dealing with
JavaScript in the browser how do you
register a service worker from
JavaScript
how do you unregister a service worker
hmm
from JavaScript
that doesn't sound good
and that's I told the people that came
up with this proposal like yeah but you
can unregister that
and they looked into that
of course they didn't say like oh yeah
you're right we'll drop it we'll drop it
all no deal it's like yeah but
if you unregister this this is literally
from the spec if you unregister it it
only gets unregistered the next time you
load the application because you have to
really it's not gonna remove it from a
running app it's just gonna mark it as
this is going to be deleted but if
you're still running you can still use
it until you stop running and then if
you reload the app you're supposed to
re-register the service worker anyway so
it it's plugged
but it really isn't because the browser
this is again this story of blinders I'm
like oh we focus on this thing and we
ignore everything else that the attacker
can do because there's a way to bypass
this mechanism you can unregister it and
then create a new browsing context like
an iframe
and then run like a silent flow in an
iframe and it's a new context without
service worker and will go straight
through
just like that
and I can show you that
just to make make clear that this not
for you but for other people who might
see this later that this is not gonna
work
now I have to be very honest here
I absolutely hate service workers if
you've ever worked with them it's a
freaking nightmare to keep them up to
date all of that stuff so I don't really
like them so I didn't spend too much
time on this demo so I didn't build a
full OLED scenario with a full working
service worker I just built a simple
proof of concept and in the proof of
concept I have a fake API endpoint
pretending to be an authorization server
I'm going to show you that when we
register that service worker we can no
longer reach it
and I'm going to show you how we can
reach it afterwards all right
seriously if you thought the previous
demo looked like crap this is not going
to get better
um
there we go
here's our service worker application
um there's no payload being injected yet
so nothing really happens but if you
would look at the application Tab and
the service worker you can see we have
one registered for restaurant.com so
this is the service worker registered
here what's going to happen is in the
back end we have our server
right here
nope
we have our server right here we have an
API endpoint slash API slash test kind
of a good indicator it's a big demo and
this is the real authorization server
like if we see this message we're
calling the real authorization server
however in our service worker we we have
it here in our service worker we are
replacing that response with this is a
service worker not the real one you
can't touch it haha and that's
essentially it so this is the code to
intercept requests we intercept fetch
calls that's at the API call for Network
stuff we check if it's a call to slash
API something something not the best way
to do that but whatever and we respond
with that fake response all right
what does that mean this means if we go
to the browser and we look at the
network tab here
let me clear this and we call the API
you can see it's a call to
slash API slash test and here in the
console you can see this is the service
worker showing you that you cannot reach
the authorization server that's the
whole idea we register that thing and we
block calls where we want to block them
like you can't send this request we're
not allowing you to do so
all right
onto
the attack
let me grab it from here
here's the attack what do we do in the
attack view let me show you the attack
file it's hosted from the same server
but I'm going to use a malicious domain
so it's coming from the malicious server
on top you can see that we're going to
unregister the service worker right here
we're going to get active registrations
and then unregister all of them and they
will disappear all right how does that
work here we go we
add it right here
payload is injected we used an image tag
this time because I don't know why the
SVG didn't work for some reason but the
image the browser is trying to load a
non-existing image handles an error
Handler instead which is our code and we
have unregistered service worker we can
see that
here if we go to service workers
you can see that this one is deleted
it's marked for deletion it's not gone
yet because this application uses that
service worker and you can see that by
calling the API again let me show you
here call the API we still get that
service worker response it's not yanked
out of a running application it's just
like yeah next time you reload we're
going to delete this and give you the
raw but then we would re-register that
service worker anyway so this seems like
a good defense all right let's update
our attack
let's call that API endpoint which is
the authorized endpoint of an
authorization server in an iframe and
see what happens so we first unregister
and then we called it an iframe
and we run this again so let me clear
this
there we go the service worker is
registered
is deleted by now we load that iframe
with the authorized endpoint where we
would run that silent flow and we get
the actual API response not the one from
the service worker and this is how you
can bypass these things this is not how
this is to illustrate this one still
works by the way the service worker is
still there for that context but the
iframe is a new browsing context the
deleted service worker doesn't get
registered there and this doesn't solve
it and that's essentially what I'm
trying to say here
yelling at the cloud
and it brings us
to this takeaway
the same one as three slides ago you
cannot secure browser only flows because
if you come up with a mechanism that you
can use from within the application
there's very likely a way you can also
unuse or unregister that from within the
application and everything you think
about there's
virtually always going to be a way to
bypass that
so no matter how sophisticated you make
this because this is going to be a
nightmare to build and maintain by the
way I can tell you that but no matter
how sophisticated you make this is not a
bad towards security it's always going
to be the same problem over and over
again
and that's a very depressing
takeaway I know but if I'm not done yet
I have a couple more minutes left
so what do you do then how can we fix
this
and that's really inconvenient part
comes in there is a perfect solution for
this it's just not as pretty as we would
wish it to be because this is what we
had before we had our front-end app
using the authorization server directly
and contacting apis with access tokens
that's the bad part because if this one
here gets compromised the attacker can
do this as well because there's no
client Authentication
and solution
is using a BFF
because if you add a BFF into the mix a
BFF is a back end for front end it's a
back-end component your backend
component can handle oauth stuff
your front that now becomes the green
box that's your that's your front-end
application it's a front-end app just
like before with an added back-end
component a very small one a very
insignificant well not insignificant
very
non-complicated components but this
solves the problem why because now in
step one we have client Authentication
there's no more running flows from the
browser because when you exchange the
authorization code for tokens the
authorization server is going to be like
hey man where's your secret or where's
your key based authentication or prove
that you are the legitimate client and
the attacker can't do that
and if you want to use a refresh token
refresh tokens first of all are not
accessible in the browser anymore
there's no tokens here
and refresh tokens used here require
client authentication no more bear
refresh tokens
awesome
this pattern is really really awesome
it looks super ugly because like oh my
God now I have a backend for my front
end but it's just it can be a very
simple stateless thing it does two
things well actually I have a slide on
that in the next slide I'm going to
highlight the changes to your
architecture to make this work
step number one
you can remove all the oad stuff from
the front end
really no more flows in the front end
you can delete your SDK your library
you're using or God forbid your custom
code to run an oad flow delete all of it
awesome this is gonna run with yes
delete your service workers absolutely
this
relies now on cookies
you have a call from the front end to
that BFF and the browser just attaches a
simple cookie to it that's it no more
code for dealing with that in the front
end awesome
your API
that's the most important Point your API
doesn't change
because your API was built for accepting
access tokens and guess what it gets
access tokens just like that zero
literally zero changes to your API
awesome your authorization server
doesn't really change yes you have to
change a client from being a public
client to a confidential client meaning
it has a secret or a way to authenticate
that's the only change it's a matter of
configuration everybody supports that
this is not a New Concept very simple
very straightforward very easy to handle
and then a BFF sounds like this holy
crap now we have to build a back end but
it's not a back end
it's a glorified proxy
it does two things it gets a request on
the incoming endpoints an API call the
Frontline calls slash BFF reviews to get
a list of reviews and there's a cookie
there and the BFF takes that cookie
opens it up takes the tokens out
checks if the access token is still
valid if it's valid slaps it on the
request and sends it to the API it's a
proxy
and the API will send a response back
and the BFF returns a response to the
front of it and if the access token here
is no longer valid the BFF will use a
refresh token first get a new access
token use that access token here and
that's it
the BFF does not contain business logic
you don't have to implement rules there
you can even implement this as a generic
BFF that you just give a config file
like here some incoming endpoints they
map to these outgoing endpoints here's
your authorization server and that's it
if you're a good developer if you're a
smart developer better than I can
develop stuff and hopefully design as
well and then you can easily build
something like that that works out of
the box with a config file
yeah just a second I'm gonna finish the
story and then I have plenty of time for
questions
so this is really
fairly simple it can run as a stateless
service you don't have to spin up like a
tomcat in the back end to make the
supported BFF you can if you want to
like some people really hate their jobs
so they might want to use it don't get
server for that but you can do this as
as a stateless Azure function or AWS
Lambda function or whatever that would
be perfectly possible as well might cost
you a bit in computing power but that's
that's all there is
what about this guy
we haven't really fixed our crosshatch
scripting problem now have we
no we haven't cross that scripting is
still there and the attacker can still
inject malicious code in the browser but
now they can't get tokens because
there's no tokens here and they can't
run a flow with the authorization server
because there's no tokens there
that's good
the attacker still has access to the
front-end application they can still
change the page which have always been
possible or able to do and it can still
send requests through the back end
the BFF we know that attack a session
writing this is not something new this
is something from the 90s
that we had an old traditional web
applications and that we still have
today that's by the way why you should
fix your cross scripting as well don't
just leave it there and focus on the
oauth stuff but now
we can reduce the attack surface from
the full API or apis that the token had
access to to only the endpoints that the
BFF exposes if this front that needs
three endpoints and the BFF should only
expose three endpoints not then and the
attacker can only access these three not
the other seven
that's a win additionally and this is
very optional by the way but now you
have also a single point of control and
you could Implement things in your BFF
like rate limiting or anomaly detection
or something like that you could decide
like hey why is this client sending 10
000 requests per minute that makes no
sense I'm gonna kick him out like no
you're no longer allowed to contact me
go get new tokens and we'll talk about
it then that could also be a possibility
but again that's not mandatory
and that is essentially how a BFF
increases security and yes there's a
cost to it this doesn't come for free
like always
but in this case for sensitive
applications the cost the the benefits
far outweigh the costs
I'm not talking about using BFFs for
your grandmother's recipe application I
mean if you build that stuff over the
weekend you can that's a good exercise
but it's probably not worth it to do it
there because honestly nobody cares but
if you're building Healthcare apps
financial apps apps dealing with
personal information this should be
absolutely mandatory
and if you're building Healthcare apps
in Norway it is mandatory because he
enforces that
you're not allowed to register a
front-end only client for using their
system that's one way of doing that and
by the way whenever I talk about BFS
people come to me after I talk like yeah
I work in healthcare or in finance and
we've been using BFFs all along I mean
we don't care about the extra load that
it puts on our servers yeah of course we
do that so it's it's not an uncommon
pattern and it uses it works quite well
all right let me wrap this up here and
then we'll answer some questions
I have to add a disclaimer to be
completely Fair
that spec on browser-based apps does
mention a BFF as well mostly because
otherwise people like me and Dominic
keep asking them about it and
complaining about like yeah but BFFs are
the solution so they're like yeah let's
add a BFF there's no details by the way
there's like yeah yeah you can add a BFF
but crosstalk scripting is still a
problem that's basically the summary of
what's in the spec if you don't believe
me go check it out by the way the
section before BFF is like yeah maybe
you don't use a lot at all because it's
kind of insecure that's literally the
section before that it adds more stuff
to your attack surface that you maybe
don't need at all so I'm going to leave
it in the middle how useful this section
is but I wanted to mention that it's
there
key takeaways
three
you cannot secure browser only Flows In
All Out
yes it's inconvenient but it's the truth
I've Illustrated why this is not
possible and I'm sure you can think of
another pattern and I'm sure somebody
pretty smart will think of a way to
bypass that you simply cannot do it
because all the security hinges on
controlling that redirect URI and if the
attacker does that everything else goes
out the window
BFFs solve the problem
more or less they reduce the
consequences of a successful Crosshair
scripting attack they reduce the attack
from getting tokens and long-term access
to an online session riding attack
that's as As Good As It Gets we can't do
better with the presence of cross
unscripting that's just a reality
and that's why take away 3 is there
follow secure coding guidelines so you
can try and prevent that trusted
scripting in the first place because if
you can do that
the rest of the story becomes a bit less
relevant you should still do it as a
defense in depth and secure architecture
but fixing crosshatch scripting is
priority number one here and in that
light if you want to know how follow one
of my security workshops or
alternatively I have a whole bunch of
articles on my website about cross-site
scripting in angular and react and how
you can use trusted types and CSP and
all of that stuff so check it out
if you just go to my website you'll
easily find it or the link is here at
the bottom
if you want to learn more I have some
online courses you can check out as well
if you like listening to me if you don't
like I don't recommend these because I'm
going to be talking for a long time in
these courses if you want to know more I
have a mailing list on my website that's
the best way I have a couple of things
in the pipeline for this year so
subscribe to stay up to date no spam
just security content and with that I
want to thank you and if you have any
questions I'll happily answer them right
now
all right you had a question in the back
is that still there
no I was about to cross that scripting
in BFFs no okay well glad I answered it
anyway I have no idea what I said with
that sure
yes
but it still needs to keep uh if you
want to get access tokens by okay that's
a state
yes in this case you can push tokens to
the client in cookies so cookies can be
made inaccessible from JavaScript so you
can hide them from malicious JavaScript
they're still there on requests but not
on the client-side context you can store
your access token and refresh token in a
cookie preferably you encrypt that
cookie for additional security but it's
not even mandatory and that way your BFF
doesn't have to keep any state because
every incoming call will carry those
cookies you can grab the tokens from
there
see if they if the access token is valid
if not use the refresh token and then
send a request to the API
yes you'll have
you'll have a bit of cookie size well
not issues but
um there is two tokens in the cookie and
some metadata probably but that the
bulky token is going to be the access
token and guess what you already
included on the in the authorization
header anyway so now it's not in the
authorization header but in the cookie
so to be honest it's not going to add
much to your request sizes
other questions
all right
no there's a question so the spec
mentions the BFF pattern also mentioned
is another pattern which is called
something called the mediator pattern
yeah there's like a token mediation
pattern that's like a half-assed BFF
it's well it's not a joke it's the
reality it's like a it solves half of
the problem as in it's
no it it's actually not that bad it's
it's basically a token mediation pattern
is a BFF that runs the OLED flow on the
back end it keeps a refresh token on the
back end but allows the front end to use
the access token to call apis directly
um
it's mainly there for people that have
very
um response heavy apis because every
request otherwise tunnels through the
BFF so now you can make direct calls so
you don't have that proxy component in
the middle
um security properties are not that bad
but usually for security sensitive apps
you want to go to the full BFF anyway
but yeah it's it's there it's a it's a
it's a valid pattern um might be a good
in between if you need it it does solve
the getting fresh tokens part so that's
good
yes if you have a csrf policy would it
be able to protect against the attack
you show them would that be remote
um it's if you have a cross-sight
request for degree policy um it would
not have any impact on this attack
because the attack is not against your
apis where you would have to see surf
policy in place it's basically running a
flow with the authorization server so
that's something you have no control
over and csrf detect protections
wouldn't work here anyway because c-surf
is about cross-site request forgery it's
if I want to send a request from my evil
domain maliciousfood.com to the back end
of restorate.com that's a cross-site
request but here the attacker is already
in restaurant.com so they can send
requests as if they were the application
sees of protections matter for your BFF
so if you want to go back
back here by the way I oh I forgot that
I'm Dominic is looking at me very
angrily he's doing a talk right after me
and he's going to dive into the details
of BFFs that's why I haven't talked
about details and I totally forgot to
mention that so ah yeah he's going to be
very angry at me but that's a different
story but sea surf protections would
matter here so that the malicious
frontland would not be able to send
requests to the BFF and get them handled
but um most cases a very well most cases
you run these things in the same origin
the same domain and then you just don't
accept crosshat requests problem solved
and otherwise a solid course policy will
solve that as well but Dominic will talk
about that in the next session which is
is it here same room one I think oh in
the bigger room right awesome I will not
be offended by that
yes
say a few words about how a typical user
login flow fits into the beer I will
cover that yes he will cover that
let me try to take a stab at it and it
wouldn't change much
um you still click a button in your
Frontline like I want to log in and the
front then just asks the BFF please
start a an or flow and the BFF will
generate all the parameters like pixie
and so on and so on and then just send
the redirect and response so uh that's
in a nutshell how it should work
um just very much like you would have a
login flow for a back-end web
application same story basically
but he's going to cover that so more
details uh in a minute well in 10
minutes
sure
information if you still want to keep
secure
what's your commands
yeah so what what about applications
that are not super sensitive but still
need to be secured obviously and what do
you do um it depends on your threat
model depends on
what kind of data do you handle for
example if you have an app that doesn't
load like third-party contents like
Twitter timelines and stuff like that
and you don't really handle user data
you just do some business operations so
there's no real untrusted data then your
trap model may be like yeah this is
acceptable for us it's it depends on
whether you want to accept the risk
and be aware of that at least document
like hey we know about this BFF thing we
decide not to use it because of these
reasons and then if one of these reasons
is wrong in the future you at least know
like oh yeah whoops we missed that
um but yeah you could you could do that
and the moment you're like oh this is
risky that's when the the trade-off
becomes viable right then this one like
oh this is too risky so yes okay let's
invest time and money into building that
BFF and using that
um so yeah I can't really answer that
for you it depends on what you're doing
I'm using a lot straight up in the front
end it's not the end of the world it's
just not something
that you really want to do in critical
applications business sensitive
applications
yes
yeah I'm gonna shoot myself
sorry uh so yeah
in the browser outside of JavaScript
that's a good question
um
that's a really good question I think it
can yes
I think if we would
I would have to think this true
not just like in a minute in a
conference talk but you have to think
it's true but of the top of my head I
would say if you can fully abstract away
the or details like we do now in a BFF
you in theory could move that in a
browser component which also fully
encapsulates tokens by the way so if
that's possible then yeah this this can
probably work Dominic has something to
say about that I should mention a Google
Google is looking at that yes they they
are looking at implementing native
authentication apis and things like that
into the browser which means every time
you're doing an overall or an openly
connect flow it will go via Google
servers happy with that
yeah so
yeah
it's hard yeah but my first instinct
would be to say that it seems like you
could take that BFF and put that part in
the browser itself
um but then the the fun part becomes
like getting it actually interoperable
because oledc is fairly extended usually
standards compliant but a lot has like
r0 has their own custom things and
everybody else wants to add values here
and this there and it gets a bit tricky
but in theory it should be possible
um I just don't think we'll ever see
that happen but sure
security manager that is a security
tools
well now you have a doctor sent him so
uh
watch this one well it's going to be
online later I'm going to be in the
picture like half of the time so that
should be good
um and you can tell them like just watch
this and then we'll talk about that yeah
sure
anybody else
all right in that case the class is
dismissed so enjoy the rest of the
conference if you
if you want to talk more just grab me
during one of the breaks here I'll be
here until the afternoon somewhere
thank you